the gyro can experience ripping apart
like the imagine that that used to be
show business used to be like in a
covered wagon
you'd pull into town ladies and
gentlemen gather around and there was a
show and then you know you have a
minstrel show and people would sing and
do puppets and it'd be a play you yeah
that's when when do you think the first
guy got up and told jokes and made
people laugh like when was our first Oh
who's that guy he wrote that he wrote
that great book on the history of
stand-up and it was a guy like Frank Fay
or something like that who was the first
guy that went out there like I don't
need to have like a [ __ ] hula hoop
and spinning plates and he just went out
and was like I'm just gonna tell stories
and make him like he kind of did a
monologue type of thing but uh he was
the first guy if I haven't Rises that I
think was the 20s and then in the 40s he
was actually on the side of the fascists
he was a fascist yeah there was really
yeah there was people in this country
that you know didn't think what those
guys were doing was necessarily wrong
which really if you look at the history
forget about this country a humanity
like there's always been that so what
[ __ ] his career if I'm remembering
this correctly this could be like
[ __ ] hope I'm saying the right guy he
so he ended up doing this
yes Frank face stand up he did this show
all right I guess that's earlier when
he's doing the props he's come out
dressed like he's in the Foreign Legion
but he did a show right after World War
two where after he won and it was a
pro-fascist rally in New York City and
he was the big name he signed on to do
it and the night was called the Friends
of Frank Fay the first stand-up comic
was a fascist house I know I can't say I
don't I don't know that but then there's
other people that I got a body mind that
will argue that that Mark Twain was
Samuel Clemens yeah
well argue will argue that he was the
first stand-up so I don't know really
nice I think it just sort of
they would sort of poked its head up and
then duck back down like somebody improv
the line like hey I did that without my
hula-hoop you know hey you know what
good
[Applause]